anyway
so remember our friend
we've talked about him on the show
played a lot of his music on here in
rotc too on both
you remember uh songwriter x
and his wife well
apparently a couple years ago
from what i gathered jimmy fallon made
fun of them
and boy were they not happy about it
title of this video is jimmy fallon you
don't have to be mean to be funny
let's check it out hello i'm
x and i'm susie and we're with
songwriter x and the
skeleton band and jimmy fallon
we got a bone to pick with you and
that's why we're standing on your set
here
it's a green screen yes we just have a
few things we think you ought to know
we're amused but some other people might
not be
do not play i am not amused uh
jimmy i am not a muse at all
boy he is not amused this is not gonna
get
well i think that's a very cool cruel
thing you're doing to people
i mean you're in a position of power
being at the top of the
entertainment pyramid and instead of
using your power
to help people to help the one musicians
on the trenches socials ourselves
you decide to pick on people in the
musicians in the trenches
they think they're in the trenches and
have fun
at their expense well i am not amused
susie might be but i am not
it is true what if he had done that to
justin bieber
you know nobody would care
anyway and jimmy another thing when
you're doing this do not
play list or whatever it is that you do
make sure you listen to the song first
the do not play list so i guess he did
something where he didn't want
like things you shouldn't listen to we
could tell
that you had never listened to the song
and and had no idea
yeah because you couldn't even remember
the simple words in the chorus yeah
it's the bad it's a bad okay guys look i
don't defend jimmy fallon i don't like
jimmy fallon
but come on watch the video you would
have noticed that we danced on water
do you think that all your subscribers
are because you're good
because sometimes there's people that
are bad like you know he has 20 000
subscribers
sometimes people they're bad and they
know they're bad and they know that's
why i'm getting subscribers because
people you know like watching me because
i'm bad you know like
the dark side phil thing but these guys
think that they're good
i don't like jimmy fallon jimmy fallon
is a piece of [ __ ]
you know that i i don't need to tell you
you've seen me rip them apart
however let's hear these guys out
instead of you say oh they should have
photoshopped themselves
in a water well we did dance on water
and what i want to do now
so we know you didn't see it
so what i want to do now he is
not happy with her did you see that
let's watch that did you see that let's
watch that
dance on water and what i want to do now
so we know you didn't see
it
she made him very angry
so what i want to do now i want you to
watch your clip
and after you watch your clip we're
going to give you some suggestions
oh good i'm excited for this to better
this enterprise
i'm excited uh oh this next uh song is
from a band called
songwriter x in the skeleton band
that sounds scary right it sounds scary
yeah yeah here's the album cover here
that's it
that's it's a pretty pretty good cop
cover
i don't know which one's songwriter x
maybe she is dance on water
so dance dance on water
is the name of the thing it looks almost
like this album is photoshopped but
do you think they would photoshop
themselves dancing on water if that's
the name of the
single anyway doesn't matter here's
dance on water
if i could dance
if i could dance on water i'd dance a
dick for you
if we could dance the water
[Music]
[Applause]
who taught the guy to say water though
he's not saying water is saying who put
that out though
skeleton i don't know man songwriter x
and the skeleton band
i just think if you could do this song
you got to say i mean saying
if i could dance on water
uh anyway that's that's dance on water
jimmy what's the other guy lamont lamont
isn't that hawker you guys were giggling
like a couple of little girls you had no
idea what you were watching
you just were told to be funny and it
wasn't funny
and how would you like it they had been
done to you
before you made it and you're wearing it
let me tell you something
hold on a second hold on a second
as somebody who has been an expert at
making fun of jimmy fallon through his
whole career um
as somebody who was an expert at making
jimmy fallon for a very very long time
i'll tell you this jimmy fallon
was made fun of plenty okay
for always breaking on snl for being the
worst part of snl
jimmy fallon was made fun of by family
guy
american dad a lot of cartoons a lot of
people
a lot of people have made fun of jimmy
fallon so let's not sit here
and pretend i'm not defending jimmy
fallon i will always make fun of jimmy
fallon jimmy fallon is
very very easy to make fun of but let's
not [ __ ] pretend
like jimmy fallon hasn't been made fun
of through his entire career
taking it too kindly i don't think the
thing is
you have these uh do not play but it
would be a lot
nicer if you had to do play with your
power as on the top of the entertainment
pyramid
you could help artists if you had a do
playlist and you mentioned a ban or two
every week that would be a great thing
for everybody
that would be something and you would
look good instead of
looking like a mean cruel
you know what i mean jimmy fallon's
[ __ ] sucks and he's stupid he's a
piece of [ __ ]
and he's not funny he's an over laughter
overlapper and he's just doing a
just a [ __ ] toned-down variety show
every night
whatever and he's an sjw signaling [ __ ]
who probably has a drinking problem and
a coke problem probably i don't know if
that's true but that's what it looks
like
but they wouldn't call him the mean one
he's not the mean one
jimmy kimmel's more the mean one jimmy
you don't have to be mean to be
funny no you don't have to be mean at
all and you don't have to be cruel
to it's just the casual cruelty kind of
thing
like you're stepping on people that
don't mean anything to you
and you know what that's not right
sometimes that's their life's dream
are they going to turn into the joker is
this what happened in the joker movie
yeah you're stepping on people's dreams
jimmy
fallon speaking of stepping how about
dancing a
jig jimmy well
here come dance and water i suggest that
you watch it from beginning to end
and you might learn something and you
may just like it
and by the way we do have
over 2 million views between facebook
and youtube so we're not
exactly nobody hmm
you're kind of nobody so i mean i'm a
nobody so
from a nobody to another you're kind of
a nobody
have fun enjoy dance on water yeah
take care yes
yes
[Music]
yeah let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice let's dance on water baby let's do
it everyone together come on
[Music]
if i could dance on water
if i could dance on water
if i could dance on water i danced a
dick for you
if i could dance a worm
if i could dance somewhere
if i could dance on water i'd dance a
jig for you
exactly how can they believe this is
good but forget all that
it looks like they're making a
mde sketch or tim and eric's sketch or
that absurdist comedy is what it looks
like they're doing
if they were to embrace it and go yeah
we're just trying to make people laugh
it would go over a lot better but man
looking at the beginning of this [ __ ]
little jimmy fallon rant thing
they take this [ __ ] really seriously
[Music]
went up the hill to get a drink
quite a scene jack fell down
broke his crown jill came after
there is that his wig jack got up
went to bed on his head
jill came in she left that jacks this
last stop
if i could dance on water
if i could dance on water
if i could dance on water i'd dance a
jig for you
if i could chance the water
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry you're supposed to take this
are we supposed to take this seriously
because if i just saw this and we've
played their other videos they take
themselves seriously
um what are you supposed to do with this